what would you do to have a pair of
glasses that is not only powered by
augmented reality but also synchronizes
with your phone to show you things such
as your emails texts a map of wherever
you are or gives you directions for
where you're headed all of these without
you even having to pull out your phone
well these are some of the things that
the Apple glasses will help you do but
what if I tell you that the Apple
glasses will also conform to anyone's
prescription needs and that's why
thousands of people like me have been
waiting excitedly for these eyewear for
many many years now but unfortunately we
will have to wait longer well till at
least 2025 but what are the other things
to expect from the Apple glasses that
make this eyewear so special and could
the Apple glasses be the product that
eventually replaces the iPhone history
of the Apple glasses this story began
way back in 2014 when thousands of
spyglass lovers around the globe were
heartbroken because of Google's Smart
Glass failure the Google Glass failed
because back then people weren't really
interested in this type of tech and also
because of some design challenges but
their hopes were soon revived when news
about Apple's smart glasses became the
Talk of the Town in 2017 and I can tell
you that no one is as excited as Apple's
CEO Tim Cook about the prospects of
diving into virtual and augmented
reality he made a passionate speech
about Apple's interest in mixed reality
devices during the worldwide developers
Conference held at San Jose McHenry
Convention Center in 2017. and speaking
with apple sleuth timberjarin at a
private event Tim Cook explains that
virtual and augmented reality could be
one of Apple's greatest contributions to
the tech World Tim may be right after
all because Apple did get the world's
attention with the Apple glass
unfortunately it seems we'll have to
wait longer than expected as the launch
has been delayed till around 2025 due to
some serious technical issues with the
Apple glass according to timberjarin
Apple didn't start developing the smart
glasses immediately after the worldwide
developers conference instead Apple took
a systematic approach by creating
software applications that could be
delivered on iPhone phones and iPads
these applications will eventually be
used on the Apple glass we could assume
that apart from making the tech world
happier Apple's technological strides
are largely in effect because they are
trying to introduce a perfect glass
model to the world and as we can see
from the indefinite postponement Apple
isn't ready to risk the tiniest floor in
its most ambitious project if Apple gets
things right it could result in a
profitable expansion of the AR market
for life what's more it will make people
believe that a device as unique as this
could be more than just science fiction
or what you see in a superhero movie the
third and fourth quarter of 2022 was
greeted with several rumors and
speculations about Apple glass
interestingly some of these viral
stories made sense While others were a
little out of line also several leaked
patents suggest what Apple glass might
look like but from what we know about
Apple and I guess most tech companies in
general they can issue hundreds of
patents and only a few of them
eventually get used however it seems
like the picture is getting clearer on
what we might be expecting to see if the
Apple glass ever gets launched overall
design it's no longer news that the
Apple glass will be produced in the
similitude of Google smart glasses it
will be produced with lightweight
material that will make it convenient
for longer and outdoor use the best
thing about the Apple glass is its AR
feature users will get to see digital
information overlaid in the real world
and guess what the Apple glass will
share data directly from your iOS device
sadly Apple's Tech Geeks are yet to get
their hands on lightweight Hardware that
will possess the power of an iPhone as
well as a sufficient battery life to
sustain it many of the things we know
about the design of the Apple glass are
from leaked patterns some of which
illustrate Apple glass as a safety
wearable but if apple is going to steal
the hearts of millions of apple-centric
people with the smart glasses then it
has to be fashionable aside from its
technical qualities people want to look
cool on Apple glass and not like some
two-decade old Terminator at no offense
Arnold nonetheless Apple has in the past
displayed sleekness and style in its
designs from the earliest to the most
recent and we can say based based on
this fact that the design of Apple glass
might not be disappointing why in May
2022 Apple analyst John Prosser
suggested that Apple glass will look
like the pair worn by its founder Steve
Jobs with respect to some sort of
Heritage Edition wouldn't that be nice
however Apple sleuth Mark German says
that John pross's disclosure could well
be a rumor moreover Tim Cook hasn't said
anything about the glasses except
heaping Praises on the prospects of
augmented reality to say the least the
design for Apple glass wouldn't be
different from your normal glasses going
by the pictures we've seen on the
internet the eyewear will have a light
detection and ranging scanner also known
as lidar scanner on the right Temple
this scanner will help the user create
fast accurate and realistic 3D
representations of close range objects
and environments however the Apple
glasses do not come with any inbuilt
cameras still lidar helps position
objects without physical markers in
seconds the first generation of Apple
glass will also come with the stand and
a wireless charging dock the battery
life is also expected to be around on
three hours but if charging the Apple
glass would be as easy as charging
airpods then the short life span
wouldn't be much of a problem apart from
the glasses the lenses are also another
feature that make the Apple glasses
pretty special special lenses one of the
major things to expect from the Apple
glass are its special lenses Apple has
been granted a patent that reveals that
the smart glasses will accommodate all
eye conditions despite their severity
using an optical sub-assembly Apple
glass will automatically adjust to the
user's eyesight however several analysts
claim that this feature is likely to be
used in developing the augmented and
virtual reality headset that Apple has
picked over the development of smart
glasses and if not perhaps we'll get to
see it in the second edition of Apple
glass another patent shows that apple is
making attempts to increase user
experience by projecting the image right
into the user's eye this way it becomes
way easier to focus on particular images
this feature however doesn't prevent the
smart glasses from doubling as
prescription glasses also going by a
2019 CNET report which indicated that
the Apple glasses were projecting 8K
users can expect a stunning 7680 by 4320
pixel resolution for each eye if and
only if the report turns out to be true
several other patents suggest that Apple
glass can project parts of the world you
wish to see allows you to change
backgrounds seamlessly and for the
secret government agents watching this
video Apple glass depth sensors will Aid
night vision there are also talks of
Apple glass having a privacy eyewear
feature that keeps your iPhone display
private but more importantly another
patent has revealed wearables in the
form of smart rings that will Aid finger
movement and gestures to which Apple
smart glasses must work accordingly
let's say you're using a pen for
instance well an apple pen the smart
Rings will help translate whatever
movements you make with your fingers
into handwritten text and according to
Apple sleuth Ming Chi quo the Apple
glass may use Sony micro OLED displays
and Optical modules to improve its
see-through AR experience and in the
same vein provide an impressive VR
experience Apple glass privacy going
back to privacy one of the major
problems with apple glass might be the
idea that users can record or photograph
people without their knowledge and I
guess Hollywood has made us aware of
this fight when Google Glass came out in
2013 a Seattle bar called The Five
Points Cafe publicly banned the use of
Google Glass from their premises for the
same reason Apple didn't need to have
that experience with their hmds before
protecting people's privacy so they got
a patent that allowed for recording
indicators to alert bystanders when
they're being recorded however this
patent is more suitable for Apple's AR
VR headset since Apple didn't install an
extra camera on Apple glass and even if
we're taken by surprise we can be sure
that both users and bystanders privacy
is protected also the pattern suggests a
removable camera accessory module its
absence signifies the hmd user cannot
record it also provides theaters and
bars like the five-point Cafe leverage
against illegal filming or photographs
Apple glass May detect sound Elite
pattern suggests that the Apple glass
features several microphones that helps
it detect even the littlest sound and
lead the user to the detected sounds via
an indicator AR kit we already know that
Apple has been in the business of AR for
years and each version of iOS contains
newer AR features and as I said earlier
these captivating features are a
systematic approach to Apple's most
ambitious AR Tech going forward location
anchors on the AR kit will allow Apple
glass users to affix AR objects to
real-world locations in other words
sporting Apple glass or Apple's mixed
reality headset will allow you to see
these objects without physical
interaction objects like locations signs
directions and almost everything you see
daily also Apple glass users can create
a 3D map of a specific location in
seconds using capture depth data and
anchor points Apple has also added face
and hand tracking software to the AR kit
with it users can expect an immersive
gaming experience and they'll also be
able to translate sign language Apple
glass software and price it's been
rumored that apple is already developing
two AR VR platforms the first is based
on iOS slash reality operating system
also known as Ros which suggests it will
only work on your iPhone and the other
on Mac OS extended reality operating
also called xros and as the name implies
it will only work on your Macbook so the
Apple glass is likely to use the Ros in
addition to this a 2020 leak reveals
that the Apple glass will employ an
operating system codenamed starboard
interestingly back in 2019 a few codes
were discovered inside the builds of
Apple's IOS 13 with the codename
starboard or Star tester as I've said
over and over again Apple relies on a
series of developing systems for its
latest technology but whilst we can go
on and on about the interesting features
of the Apple glasses one important
question is would you be able to afford
it John Prosser discloses that the Apple
glass will cost 499 dollars separate
from the cost of prescription lenses the
lenses are likely to be custom made so
depending on your insurance plan plans
you're likely to spend around fifteen
hundred dollars in total and that's
quite a pretty penny so what is Apple
doing now news about the Apple glasses
indefinite postponement isn't complete
without talking about its replacement
the mixed reality headset Apple explains
that the combined augmented and virtual
reality headset will be a stepping stone
to the development of the Apple glass
earlier patents have shown that the
headset will come with specialized
gloves the mixed reality headset is
likely to be launched this year and a
second generation which will be much
lighter and rumored to be able to take
calls will be out in 2024 and let's not
forget Apple's AR contact lenses which
analysts believe will be launched in
2030 and hopefully after this you'll be
able to cop the Apple glass from your
favorite stores